[Applause]
the architects at RCR were beside
themselves with joy when they found out
they had won the Pritzker Prize earlier
this month and the messages of
congratulations have not stopped coming
via what the new of it we got a telegram
from the Spanish royal family one of our
former lecturers sent us a gift and
people on the street keep talking to us
people who know us but strangers too
just to say congratulations if you have
a brother if your mosque if a dream has
come true a dream that we never even
dreamt of dreaming RC R stands for
Rafael Aranda karma pigeon and Ramon
Villalta the three have their office in
a former foundry building in the small
Catalonian town of Allah they work a lot
in the region they designed this library
in Barcelona a modern steel and glass
structure that merges well with the
surroundings and a sports facility in
oullette surrounded by trees
they filled a void in the town of the
poi creating a space for locals it's
with projects like these that they've
made a name for themselves say no Sakura
30 fellow for Kim essentially we're
known for our smaller works
we're not architects who work on a huge
scale or for a wide audience
it's about people for us boobity cosmo
see if we always ask ourselves what a
building wants to be and how will people
end up feeling in this space cuando éste
en estas is party so it was quite a
sensation to win the world's most
prestigious architecture prize worth
some ninety five thousand euros won that
in the past has been awarded to star
architects known for extremely famous
buildings such as Norman Foster
the British designer of the Gherkin or
the Swiss duo Salkin Duhamel home who
designed the Olympic Stadium in Beijing
and the Elbphilharmonie in Hamburg or
the late Zaha Hadid who was the first
woman to be awarded the prize in 2004 of
course it's a great honor for us to join
the list of these Award winners but the
prize comes with a lot of
responsibilities that the jury is placed
as on a pedestal push though and now
we're getting a lot of attention
grin conocimiento no the attention is
well-deserved and not all their designs
are local they designed the salon museum
in Roday and southern France one of the
region's architectural highlights and
they're designed for the
michelin-starred restaurant les calls in
oullette is as much of a magnet as the
food it is considered a pivotal piece of
architecture they've transformed a
country house with the restaurant owners
guests and personnel in mind they've
changed the building completely they
brought nature into it light the kitchen
used to be a stall for animals it was
dark
we cooked there for 10 years without
natural light the members of the
Pritzker Prize jury were not only
impressed by the design of the buildings
they also honored the trio for their
teamwork the three have worked
democratically at the same desk for over
30 years they don't intend to stop now
Raymond thinnest supreme ADA from the
start we knew we just wanted to continue
doing things the same way this is the
way we won this valuable prize contrato
una hora pero kid no and we won't change
much we'll just continue as we've been
doing so far again donors to Camino
kumamoto just our
there are several projects in the
pipeline projects which pay attention to
the local context but are bold with
regard to form and materials
architecture that excels from rural
Spain
[Music]